a relative of my wife asked me the other
day at a party that they are getting a
fifteen thousand dollar bonus they are
getting a fifteen thousand dollar bonus
from work and they wanted to figure out
what should they do with that fifteen
thousand dollar bonus not a fifteen
dollar bonus fifteen thousand dollar
fifteen thousand dollar bonus and right
from the get go they said look roughly a
third of that is going to have to go to
taxes so this is going to be a
ten thousand dollar
after tax
after tax bonus so this is the actual
amount of money they'll have to play
with and they said they have a couple of
options there they have two hundred
thousand dollars on their mortgage on
their home mortgage and they're paying a
six percent this is this is kind of the
pre-tax six percent interest on it they
have a ten thousand dollar car loan and
it's a six percent interest on that as
well
or they could invest with an expected
return of seven percent in the market
and you have to say expected return
because in the stock market it
definitely is not a guaranteed return
now the first thing that i we when we
talked about this is well let's just
make sure that everything is kind of on
the same kind of pre or post-tax basis
or another way to think about it is
essentially what is the effective
interest rates or the effective returns
to you once you factor in taxes and the
reason why this is important
is
mortgage interest is tax deductible you
can reduce it from your stated income
and so whatever your whatever your
marginal tax rate is you can get roughly
that percentage back so if this guy is
being taxed at around one third of his
income at around 33 percent his
effective mortgage interest rate he's
gonna get about a third of this back
this will uh he'll be able to deduct all
of the interest from his income about a
third of that back will lower his actual
tax amount so his effective interest
rate is actually closer to four percent
on his mortgage when you view it from a
after tax basis the car loan is not tax
deductible you can't deduct more car
loan interest so it's effective tax rate
uh it's effective interest rate is still
six percent
and on any kind of return you get in the
market
depending on whether you think it's
going to be short-term or long-term
return you still will have to pay taxes
on it although there'll be slightly
different rates for that but we just
just for the sake of this argument let's
assume that
on an after-tax basis so this would be
pre-tax he could get seven percent but
then after tax let's say it's closer to
five percent and when you view it this
way now everything the four percent the
six percent the five percent these are
all kind of net of taxes and when you
view it this way what you should always
do is pay off or invest in the thing
that's going to get you the highest
return and sometimes you have to adjust
for uh for risk in this situation the
the costliest thing he has is this car
loan it is a six percent
it is a six percent car loan it's even
higher in interest than his after tax
return he would expect to get in the
market so the no-brainer thing to do
here and this is guaranteed he's
guaranteed to save six percent a year on
this ten thousand dollar loan if he were
to pay it off if he were to pay it off
if he were to invest in the stock market
he's not even guaranteed that five
percent might be more it might be less
there's some volatility and there's no
reason to do the mortgage because he's
only guaranteed kind of saving four
percent on this ten thousand dollars he
would pay off so in this case definitely
definitely go for the car loan